comment ça va j'espère que vous allez
bien aujourd'hui on regarde et on se
parle d'un pc doit watts et le macbook
14 heures vive la télé j'aime bien le
vieux slogan on avait ça quand on était
gamins sur les boîtes de céréales vu à
la télé ça donne une gage de qualité il
ya effectivement des spots à la télé qui
tourne avec ce macbook 14 aces
[Musique]
il a de la gueule quand même on est de
la connectique on a deux l'usb à de ce
côté là de l'autre côté on va venir
retrouver deux ports usb c'est
thunderbolt 4 on lâche des emmy 1.4 et
puis si une prise jack oui pour faire
quoi pour brancher votre casque parce
que des fois ci coûte de brancher un
petit casse comme rooney du bluetooth
également à l'intérieur mais ça j'ai
voulu détailler dans quelques instants
puis vous avez des hauts parleurs parce
que oui ordinateur sans haut parleur ce
ne serait pas un ordinateur donc un
design qui est très sympa et surtout
lorsque vous l'ouvrez intérieur et bien
vous avez un clavier ça rend service
alors il ya un truc qui va choix
intéressant je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez si vous avez un quart note mes
précédentes vidéos sur les autres
ordinateurs de huawei et bien il planqué
la webcam d'un clavier alors regardez je
vous montre ça c'est une autre machine
de huawei et la webcam elle était juste
là vous cliquez là et votre came
voyelles été cachés juste ici ou quoi
c'était super ingénierie très pratique
parce qu'effectivement et bien ça se
cacher donc en termes de confidentialité
c'était très très rassurant mais pour
autant vous étiez filmé en
contre-plongée c'est à dire qu'on venait
voir ce qui se passait dans d'autres
mais voyez donc ce n'était pas forcément
tout le plus sexy du monde donc crise
est dit et bien on va changer un peu
l'histoire et on va repasser à la bonne
vieille caméra ici elle est planqué
justice iwate webcam alors ils ont mis
en place un tout nouveau procédé c'est
une webcam qui est soudés au laser très
fine ça évite d'abord une énorme bordure
faut que ça fonctionne et surtout va
plus vous retrouvez le film est en
contre-plongée fossat quand même
vachement mieux vous en pensez quoi on
se voit comme ça coucou c'est moi alors
après ici c'est du 720p on n'a pas de
1080p sort est intéressant de monter en
1080p probablement pour une prochaine
évolution de huawei en attendant le
design me plaît bien on a un côté qui
est hyper hyper contemporain le clavier
très sympa avec des touches qui sont
faites en polycarbonate très jolie
trackpad qui est suffisamment grand très
bon retour de touche très agréable à la
frappe si vous le voyez vous avez un
petit capteur d'empreintes digitales
avec windows lots bien évidemment donc
ça déverrouille très rapidement vous
pouvez également déverrouiller grâce à
votre caméra windows et l'eau une fois
de plus il existe également une nouvelle
couleur c'est le verre épicia mais bon
moi je n'ai pas ici et surtout on est
ici 100% en aluminium ça va lui apporter
de la légèreté inquiet au 43 pour faire
de la muscu à la maison pratique aussi
16,7 mm hélas la couleur vous avez c'est
du space gré on va retrouver un écran à
l'intérieur bénéfices vous vous en
douterez plus comparé les six à
d'ordinateurs ben oui forcément c'est du
3 2 me alors vous ai déjà parlé de 3 2
me sur différents pc de huawei qu'est ce
que ça va venir apporter le 3 2 me et
bien c'est en fait un peu plus de
hauteur de visionnage là où un 16/9 sar
est réveillé à peu près par ici avec le
3/2 vous en avez un peu plus doux pour
toutes les questions de productivité bah
c'est vachement intéressant parce que
vous enverrez davantage sur votre écran
c'est un écran full view avec un ratio
de 90% 2,5 cas qui va jusqu'à 400 dit sa
part france el malki l'écran le plus
lumineux lorsque vous allez venir
travailler en extérieur en plein soleil
en juillet mais quel est l'intérêt
d'aller travailler en extérieur en plein
mois de juillet si vous êtes en plein
mois de juillet prenez des vacances ou
travaillent à l'intérieur de toutes
façons qui est trop chaud mode vie donc
on va pas dehors voilà on reste à
l'intérieur les 410 pour mieux bosser
chez vous croyez moi c'est la très très
bien il sera suffisamment lumineux comme
sarah bilahi les pousse à fond un pop up
pour la maison ça ira très bien on a un
contraste de 1500 pour en 1,07 milliard
de couleurs est extrêmement précis c'est
bien évidemment une dalle lcd j'ai un
taux de rafraîchissement 60 r on s'en
doutera mais en plus de ça je peux
passer en 90 et donc si vous voulez
venir jouer en plus ici ça peut être pas
mal pour passer en 90 hertz touche fn +
r90 serpentera plus de fluidité lorsque
vous allez me rejoint des jeux alors
attention parce qu'on aura forcément
moins d'autonomie en 90 quand 60 hertz
donc si vous n'êtes pas branché sur le
secteur et que vous voulez jouer penser
vraiment à switcher ensuite en 60 hertz
pour venir économiser votre batterie et
syndics ranque a certifié lutter contre
la lumière bleue là une certification
tuv rheinland et en plus ici vous avez
un écran tactile ça c'est pratique comme
ça vous toucher tout au bout du doigt
pour mieux naviguer très facilement
avoir un bel écran est une bonne chose
mais derrière il faut de la performance
parce que oui forcément de revenir faire
tourner des applications des programmes
des jeux tout ce qu'on veut faut qu'ils
en aient un petit peu sous le capot et
si vous en avez sous le capot alors ça
peut être la plus grosse config pour
mira tournée du gaming mais pour les
casual gamers causual gamer et bien vous
allez pouvoir bien le faire ici avec
votre machine sans problème on va partir
d'un intel core i5 jusqu'à intel core i7
série h côté graphique c'est une hélice
x graphics on n'a pas de carte graphique
dédiée elle est intégrée directement
donc c'est vraiment dans l'idée une fois
de plus du cojo ongame ans on va faire
tourner quelques petits jeux dessus sans
forcément trop de prétention c'est plus
un ordinateur qui vaquent destiné à la
productivité plus qu'à du gaming pur et
dur et si vous en voulez un petit peu
plus vous pouvez passer en mode
performance fn + paix et hop vous êtes
en mode performance pour fait la même
chose fn + p ils vont passer un mot
d'équilibré en fonction des besoins que
vous avez vous à pouvoir passer d'une
configuration à l'autre mode performance
en poussant en quatre un délice pour les
jeux et lorsque vous faites de la
bureautique un peu plus cool vous passez
en 60 hertz est en mode équilibré c'est
une machine qui est certifié et vaud on
a de la recharge rapide du wifi six
hommes dans walk apte à jouer déjà dit
et on une amélioration de la dissipation
de la chaleur avec des pales de
ventilateur qui sont complètement
optimisé elles sont seize pour cent plus
grandes au niveau de l'autonomie huawei
nous allons jusqu'à 13 heures de lecture
en 1080p alors en règle générale on va
passer à trois films pendant 13 heures
c'est une certitude mais on imagine que
sur un usage mixte on sera aux alentours
des 10 heures 9 heures 10 heures ça bien
évidemment dépendre si vous êtes sur un
mode performance ou sur un mode
équilibré ça va dépendre souhaitant 90
heures ou en 60 hertz donc une fois de
plus ça va dépendre de vous et de vos
usages et en 15 minutes de charge nous
récupérer 3 heures d'autonomie c'est de
la recharge rapide et ça c'est pratique
parce qu'ici vous avez un blog de charge
90 watts regardez c'est écrit noir sur
blanc enfin plutôt gris sur blanc alors
un truc intéressant que nous a fait
chaud et doux de marque ici à l'arrière
garde et vous avez ou white sands vous
avez ici quatre haut parleurs de twitter
pour les aigus et de hp pour les médiums
grabar dont les faits ça donne quoi un
peu plus de spécialisation sans
forcément avoir un son avec inspectent
qui est très large on reste quand même
concentré sur le médium médium grave
médium aigu par contre intéressant si
vous êtes quand même un niveau qui est
très réservée à la sa force comme on
sait qu'en ce moment il ya beaucoup de
télétravail a beaucoup de visio huawei
est venu travailler pour améliorer le
signal vous avez dû clear audio qui va
améliorer la clarté de votre voix lors
tous vos appels en visio et vous avez en
plus arrière de l'intelligence
artificielle et ail noise cancelling qui
va venir supprimer le bruit environnant
lors de vos appels évitez de vous mettre
là où il ya beaucoup de foule et
beaucoup de bruit parce que moi ça
serait un peu trop complexe mais lorsque
vous êtes chez vous il ya du bruit
machine qui tourne donc j'en sais rien
ou votre enfant qui crie derrière edel
va venir supprimer ces bruits là pour
vous permettre de vous concentrer éviter
que vos interlocuteurs capte ce qui se
passe derrière et surtout ce qui est
intéressant avec angoisse et toute la
notion d'écosystème les appareils vont
alter communiquer entre eux que ce soit
à vos smartphones qui va communiquer
avec votre pc votre pc qui va
communiquer avec un écran de huawei bien
évidemment toujours votre smartphone
avec un écran bref tous les objets vont
être interconnectés exemple ici avec
huawei cher je prends mon smartphone je
vais poser directement au niveau de mon
clavier ils vont se reconnaître et vous
voyez qu à mon smartphone qui apparaît
directement ici et c'est le truc qui est
vachement intéressant parce que regarder
c'est du mirroring alors on pourrait se
dire ok c'est bien à quoi ça sert smir
oreilles ça sert à plusieurs choses
c'est par exemple sur mon pc et que je
fais une recherche sur internet jeux
cherche monsieur heureux je vois par
exemple en taxi si bienvenue sur le site
de monsieur grelots du numérique comme
johnny et moi ok jusque là très simple
je me fais un petit copier et je veux
venir le coller ici un truc est
vachement intéressant c'est
qu'effectivement ça le fait en même
temps directement sans mon smartphone
alors là je vous montre un exemple qui
est un petit peu bullshit mais si vous
voulez faire du copier-coller facilement
entre votre pc et votre smartphone vous
le faites en temps réel très facilement
si vous voulez par exemple taper des
messages sur voie de saab directement
sur votre pc au lieu de vous embêter sur
votre smartphone et bien vous le faites
comme ça directement au temps réel enfin
bref il ya plein d' usage c'est
extrêmement pratique et pareil pour
faire du glisser-déposer c'est très
simple et par exemple si je veux faire
communiquer mon pc directement à
mountain view devrait bien évidemment
mais je peux le faire sans fil moi je
pourrais très bien évidemment hdmi mais
si je veux faire sans fil je peux le
faire et ceux ci pratique vous montre
regardez déjà sa mort mais les yeux j'ai
choisi à la source alors je vous ai déjà
parlé du medh view regardez hop je sois
ici je viens naviguer donc à une vidéo
sur le métier ou s'ils voulaient tout
savoir sur votre pc vous venez ici là
juste en bas à droite vous cliquez ici
vous allez sur projetez vous pouvez soit
dupliquer votre écran soit l'étendre à
les ovales dupliquer mais vous pouvez
les tendres si vous le souhaitez il vous
cliquez sur connecter un dispositif
d'affichage sans fil j'aime aux méduses
et yuki et laïcisme demande j'accepte
donc là je prends ma fenêtre et la
balade et jeux là mais de l'autre côté
c'est extrêmement facile je prends je
glisse je dépose donc toute cette notion
d'écosystème elle est vraiment
extrêmement important de ses ouailles
c'est l'ordinateur qui en vente ont sans
doute ramenés évidemment puisqu'on va
parleurs et si vous avez plusieurs
configurations vous avez dû 8 5 vous
avez de 8,7 dans tous les cas vous avez
16 giga drame en lp ddr 4x et vous avez
un ssd soit 512 go de stockage soit
intérêts et 500 giga de ram 512 go de
stockage de ta 1149 euros 1 il cède 16
giga de ram 512 giga de stockage vous
êtes à 1349 euros et un i7 16 giga de
ram un terrain de stockage en evo vous
êtes à
1549 euros et vous avez un casque
freebug studio qui coûta à peu près 300
euros qui vous est offert il ya des
offres pour black friday bien évidemment
son nez le lien en bagarre description
vous cliquez dessus vous allez voir ce
que vous allez match super intéressant
donc si vous voulez changer votre
machine est passé sur un nouvel
ordinateur de huawei sont le huawei made
book 14 aces et bien vous avez si une
solution qui est super intéressante une
très jolie machine de très belles
finitions ce qui est intéressant ici ce
qui me plaît bien cet écran 3 2 me qui
vous donnant un peu plus pour la partie
productivité le fait d'avoir la webcam
qui est passé sur le tour ça extrêmement
mal 1 puis surtout un très très beau
avec une fois de plus avec d'un côté
voyou et pour tout ce qui est ardu erp
microsoft et windows 10 pour la partie
software en plus il est prêt pour
windows 11 dont il vous proposera d'ici
quelques temps à passer sur windows si
vous le souhaitez et toute la
performance des puces intel à
l'intérieur donc c'est une machine qui
est intéressante dites moi ce que vous
en pensez vous en bas en commente à ce
qu'elle peut vous tentez oui non pas
comment vous marrer tout ça bien
évidemment bac quand nous on retrouve
très vite pour continuer à parler tu es
qui croyez m'en croyez moi il ya plein
de choses qui arrivent des bisous
[Musique]